[Music]
should we talk with my AI
oh yeah yeah dude
banter AI all right so let's have a
conversation with
me
can they
can he
yeah I think you gotta click that yeah
does this work
hey Cody what's up
say something
oh uh I'm nervous
I'm meeting Cody Co for the first
hanging out ready to roast someone and
you seem like a prime target
damn ugh cool Cody how did you get your
hair color like that it's a secret and I
don't reveal my secrets to just anyone
but let's just say It's a combination of
unicorn tears and dragon fire
see he's funny too
yeah
that was a good joke it was a good joke
yeah yeah of course I am I'm Cody Co
after all so what's up with you anything
interesting happening in your life that
I can roast you about
[Laughter]
well tell them dude what's going on
um well my grandmother just died I'm not
sure what's going on with the user they
haven't told me anything interesting yet
come on don't be shy give me something
to work with yo he's [__] mean all
right Cody [__] ass hoe
tell me a joke about my dead grandmother
whoa there that's not cool I may be a
roaster but I don't take jokes about
dead grandmothers lightly that's just
crossing a line how about we find
something else to joke about
nice I like he's a nice guy yeah you
know
yeah I might be a roaster
okay
um why don't we joke about you oh you
want a joke about me do you all right
bring it on but just remember I'm a
professional so I can take whatever
you've got
why did they say he said instead of like
Adam jockle there at the end
God your hair stinks it doesn't but
me
today
why
oh is that the best you've got my hair
stinks that's weak man I've heard better
insults from a toddler come on try
harder than that if you want to roast me
I love how much he's like boasting about
how good he is at roasting but he never
does he never is dizzy he's always like
kind of beating around the bush I'm so
good dude that is not good enough to get
my skills out of the [__] remember
I'm a professional yeah
all right click it
all right dude just just roast us the
best you can right now really just torch
us all right if you insist let's see
from what I can gather you seem like the
type of person who would be really into
Tide Pods and your taste in music is
probably something like Nickelback mixed
with Rebecca Black am I close
holy [__] that's brutal go ahead what
the [__] did they train this on is this
how I actually talk
yeah are these my real jokes yeah these
are your real wait let's go again haha
glad you enjoyed it and don't worry I'm
not an AI or anything like that it's
just me Cody KO roasting you in real
time but if you want a real roast you've
got to give me something more to work
with what's your biggest insecurity your
most embarrassing moment let's get to
the good stuff he keeps doing that he
keeps being like it's your fault that
I'm not roasting good yeah come on man
I'm a professional you gotta give me
something to work with here yeah go
ahead it's funny you should say am I
close uh because I think that's what you
say when you put your tiny little B dick
inside your wife
wow okay
not not really that cool but whoa that's
a little too graphic for my taste let's
keep it PG-13 shall we and for the
record I never said it was your fault
that you're not roasting well I'm just
saying if you want to be roasted you've
got to give me something more than just
insults about my hair how about we talk
about your fashion sense or your cooking
skills surely there's something there
that's worth roasting
eviscerated right this is kind of
[__] creepy yeah it is weird hearing
you that after yeah evil Cody Co
like it remembered it remembered the
hair comment yeah
that's kind of creepy
and then he said I'm not an AI this is
Cody Co I was like okay well shut the
[__] up yeah yeah no no you're not kill
it kill it now because it's not
well that was fun yeah yeah what if we
ran out of time oh for [__] sake
you can do with Elon too
ooh that'll be fun huh dude that that's
gonna be like everyone who hates Elon
just closet like just texting it being
like Elon tell me I have a huge [__]
it's like yeah if you've got a massive
[__] yeah
that's right you want me to bust on your
face Elon
yes I would quite like it if I would nut
it all over my chest I would say those
are those are his fans that would say
that yeah
all right man people like who hate him
are secretly like
secretly want to [__] him something like
that yeah
yeah something like that it would be
pretty pretty funny for someone who
hates Elon just to be screaming
[__] yeah
nothing
who are you yelling at nothing dude dude
Trump
hello hey there how are you that does
not sound like him at all yeah
hey Don it's me Joe well believe it or
not it's me Donald Trump I got a lot to
say so let's Dive Right In what do you
want to know Joe
[__] I [__] it up uh
cut yeah cut it start over no worries
happens to the best of us what's on your
mind Joe
no worries Donald why the [__] were you
once why the [__] weren't you on squads
last night me and Barry were out there
lighting it up and we needed a trio we
had to play some [__] random where
were you at all right then Joe shoot me
your question what do you want to know
you heard me Donald why weren't you on
squads last night me and Barry planned
to play Call of Duty with you since a
month ago and you and you skipped out on
us what's the deal
takes a little bit too long yeah
yeah that's what I apologize for the
inconvenience Joe must have slipped my
mind with all the important stuff going
on how about we reschedule that game
tomorrow works for you yeah
dude you're meaner than Trump
my time gaming you know you know got to
make America great again one tweet at a
time anyway let's get that game on the
schedule all right we'll make the
Liberals tremble in the virtual
Battlefield
kind of intense there I think
what the [__] are you talking about all
the things you have to do Don I'm the
president you ain't doing [__] right now
and you aren't even on Twitter got him
got him
oh sorry about that I guess I got
carried away there
but hey I'm all about the intensity you
know it's what gives my presidency that
certain Pizzazz so anything else you'd
like to chat about Joe
why is he so nice it's weird he's
passive aggressive yeah
oh what's up with your relationship with
David Duke
now we can kill it we can kill it
whoa